if you let it this world will take you
if you do not persevere and take risk to
pursue what you want to do and instead
submit to fears and uncertainties this
world would deprive you of your life and
decide what to do with you for you it
will put you in the passenger seat and
find someone or something else more
capable of doing the driving
in life there is no risk in risking it
all to become who you want to be and to
do what you want to do the only real
risk is if you never take it because if
you do not face the fears challenges and
potential setbacks on the path of doing
what you want and achieving what you
believe in life will be nothing more
than doing things you don't want to do
for things you don't believe in you will
feel sedentary in a life that requires
movement you will feel helpless in a
life that requires a sense of self
control you will feel as though you not
only fail to reach your true purpose and
ideals but that you fail to even try you
will feel weak and incomplete and you
will die without knowing what you could
have done and who you altima could've
been and with that you would already be
as good as dead long before death
arrives in the case of striving towards
your goals beliefs passions and legacy
what are you really risking by taking
risks if you are not yet excited or
fulfilled by your life then you
essentially have nothing to lose
your sense of life is incomplete your
sense of purpose is unfulfilled you have
no rational choice other than to do
anything and everything to fill it
certainly finding and filling one sense
of purpose and passion is no easy task
it can be painstaking and grueling to
find out what that even is let alone
working towards it and achieving success
in it but without this piece everything
else in life will become poisoned by the
toxicity of feeling unfulfilled or
inadequate risk it all to make your life
what you hope it can be to find a sense
of meaningfulness and control over how
you spend your time and how you impact
this world to love what you work for and
to work for what you love because the
upside of taking risks for this is
everything and the downside is most
likely just where you are now thank you
for watching if we found enjoyment and
value in this video please give it a
thumbs up share your thoughts in the
comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder